l und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus ichreiche ich dich
heute in Hamburg schneit übrigens
schneit winteru draußen liegt Schnee und
die Kemenate ist gefüllt mit einer Tüte
nach der anderen mit
Weihnachtsschmuck wie hast du hast du
Deko oder wie ja ja ich habe ja auch
schon mal glaube ich erzählt wir haben
ja eine weihnachtslampe wir haben ja
kein Weihnachtsbaum sondern eine
weihnachtslampe und wir haben die
weihnachtslampe geschmückt und danach
ist
ja steht alles was irgendwie aus dem
Wohnzimmer raus muss steht alles jetzt
in der kimenate also ich sitze jetzt
hier zwischen glitzernden Tannenzapfen
und Kugeln und so weiter also ganz
weihnachtlich
das irre da da muss ich direkt an
Alexander Hermann denken den die die
kochlegende aus Franken du bist ein
romantischer DP wusste ich gar
nicht ich habe ich ja ja so so so dass
man sich so ein bisschen kindliches
Weihnachten erhält und so weiter und ich
meine wer hat schon eine weihnachtslampe
also unter dieser Lampe hat schon als
sie noch keine weihnachtslampe war
Helmut Kohl gestanden und Ludwig Erhard
und unter meiner Lampe ja also nicht bei
mir zu Hause ich se ich se bung ja und
jetzt ich genau also die die Lampe ist
aus den unionssälen und die unionssäle
waren die die die der festtrakt des
Konrad
adenauerhauses das Krad adenauerhaus in
Bonn ist ja mal abgerissen worden ja und
unter anderem blieben dann diese
überdimensionierten Lampen übrig die
eigens für die unionsseele überhaupt
gebaut wurden herrlich ich habe dann
über ein
gebrauchtmöbelhändler ja für ein
Taschengeld diese L ersteigert und jetzt
eignet die sich super Kugeln Hand zu
hängen
ja ich gefällt mir ich apropos
alles abgerissen und alles geschreddert
über die Frage wie wir unseren Planeten
gerade abreißen und schreddern das ist
eine harte Überleitung ja wird aber
gerade in Dubai verhandelt große
Weltklimakonferenz nur mal so die so die
Eckdaten vorne weg ich find sagenhaft
allein die deutsche Delegation dürfte
der das durchschnittsklima auf der Welt
um noch mal 0,1% nach oben treiben
Mitarbeiter von denen ich jetzt gelesen
habe dass aber nur ein sehr harter ein
sehr kleiner Kern sich wirklich mit
Klimafragen beschäftigen wird was bei
mir wieder die Frage aufwirftchäftigt
sich an der
Rest alle in einem Flugzeug wie muss man
sich das vorstellen und aus
Sicherheitsgründen verteilt auf z
Maschinen so stelle ich mir das vor aber
wenn du das mal aufschlüsselst die
Kollegen von Bild haben das mal gemacht
äh und ich habe keinen Grund daran zu
zweifeln dass diese Recherche richtig
ist
äh Scholz und das Kanzleramt 40 Leute
das klimaschutzministerium von Robert
Harbeck 47 Leute bärbock
Außenministerium Rücken mit 60 Mann an
Umweltministerin Steffi Lempke 25
Mitarbeiter das finde ich
vergleichsweise zivilisiert
Entwicklungsministerium sen ja Schulze
weitere 36 Mitarbeiter das heißt eine
riesige Delegation ist immer noch nicht
ne ja ja dazu kommen noch sieben
Personen aus dem
Finanzministerium ist wichtig weil da
geht's um Kohle also um
in Kohle geht auch geht's auch genau je
F aus dem Gesundheits und
Landwirtschaftsministerium vier aus dem
Verkehrsministerium drei Bildung vier
von der Deutschen Bundesbank und auch
der Deutsche Wetterdienst das
Umweltbundesamt und das agrarinstitut
werden in Dubai personell vertreten sein
Hammer und natürlich auch
Personenschützer vom vom BKA und so
weiter aber die haben haben ja auch wir
brauchen so viele Leute weil Olaf Scholz
hat in der einer der Eröffnungsreden
gesagt wir können das 1,5 grziel noch
erreichen ja ja aber niemand gehört in
den letzten D Jahren ich habe niemanden
gehört in den letzten dre Jahren der das
ehrlich
glaubt also die ganzen Profis die ich
gehört habe zum Teil auch persönlich in
Vorträgen gehört haben gesagt nein das
schaffen wir nicht mehr das ist abgehakt
jetzt müssen wir versuchen dass wir
zumindestens 2 Grad noch schaffen aber
Olf Scholz hat noch vom 1,5° zel
gesprochen ne also der Mann ist wirklich
optimistisch das kann man nicht anders
sagen ja ja ja ja ja ja ich da könnte
man jetzt vieles zu anmerken und
irgendwann sollten wir vielleicht auch
noch mal ein eine eine Folge genau
darüber machen über Kommunikation in in
Krisenzeiten finde ich weil das ist
schon interessant was da gerade alles
passiert und vor allen Dingen auch was
nicht passiert was ich so interessant
finde ist Christian Geinitz von der FAZ
empfehle ich sehr hatten wirklich guten
Kommentar geschrieben die fossile Party
geht weiter mm
Öl und Gas sind plötzlich wieder
wahnsinnig beliebt weil
der der der der ganz neue Dreh sozusagen
wobei so neu ist der gar nicht ist und
zwar unterstützt natürlich von der
fossilenindustrie und der Mann der das
alles organisiert in Dubai s haben die
die die sehr findigen Leute von von
Fridays for future jetzt auch noch mal
sauber recherchiert das ist jand der
komplett aus diesem ganzen
aus diesem ganzen fossilen Umfeld kommt
ja also das ist auch interessant das
heißt die ganze fossile Lobby hat
da ein Haufen zu tun und ein Haufen vor
und im Grunde ist die Idee zu sagen pass
auf wir machen einfach weiter wie gehabt
aber wir scheiden CO2 einfach ab ja CCS
Carbon capture and storage ne ist das
Thema das heißt du du verbrennst
weiterhin Kohle Öl was auch immer und
verpresst dann quasi das CO2 das dabei
entsteht einfach irgendwo im Boden
äh und dann können wir im Grunde
eigentlich so weitermachen wie gehabt
das ist so ein bisschen die Botschaft
die es wahrscheinlich gar nicht ist aber
so kommt sie bei vielen vielen Leuten an
und das ist enttäuschend man muss sich
auch einmal die Summen mal vor Augen
führen die wir jetzt tatsächlich hier in
den klimatopf getan haben ja also
gemeinsam mit den Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten haben die Deutschen 200
Millionen Euro in den klimatopf getan um
Klimaschäden auszugleichen ja das hört
sich erstmal wahnsinnig viel an 200
Millionen Euro und das Schöne ist man
weiß ja aus den Neurowissenschaften dass
das menschliche Gehirn zwischen
Milliarden und Millionen nicht sauer
unterscheiden kann das geht also relativ
leicht bei vielen Menschen durcheinander
weil das fühlt sich genau gleich an 200
Millionen hört sich für manchen so an
als wür die Deutschland tut jetzt mal
richtig was ne Klimaschäden und so das
ist ein Fünftel der Baukosten der
elfilarmonie ja für die wel weiten
Klimaschäden oder um ein anderes
Beispiel zu nehmen es ist in etwa das
Jahresgehalt von Cristiano
Ronaldo also so ganz ganz viel ist das
nicht da hat man doch immer noch das
Gefühl dass die Dringlichkeit überhaupt
noch nicht angekommen zum ersten Mal
soll es ja so eine Art klimatüv geben
der zeigen wird dass das was wir tun
seit Paris seit 2015 natürlich nicht
ausreicht um überhaupt 2° zu schaffen
geschweige den
1,5° die wissen das Sch
aber im Kanzleramt ist das offenbar noch
nicht so
ganz dann denke ich immer dass das
spannende ja ist ne wenn man sich so mit
Geschichte beschäftigt dann denke ich
immer wie schwierig fällt es Menschen
realistisch einzuschätzen was im großen
Stil die gefährlichsten gefahren sind ne
also alles was was wir irgendwie
psychologisieren was unmittelbar mit
Menschen zu tun hat ja auch solche Sache
wie Krieg und so die sind ganz klar da
als Gefahr irgendwie das gehen alle
Lampen an und Warnsignale und so aber
bei solchen abstrakten Dingen wie der
Klimaveränderung ja und der drohenden
Klimakatastrophe das hat dann immer
sowas von Gottesdienst wei die Leute
gehen in die Kirche ne werden da
geläutert und gehen wieder raus ja und
schon die ersten bösen Blicke wenn man
die Nachbarn vor der Kirche trifft
zeigen ja dass man das alles sofort
wieder vergessen hat und so ähnlich
kommt mir das auch mit dem Klima vor da
gibt's so die Momente wird der
tagesschauer da irgend ausgetrocknetes
gezeigt Aralsee kein Wasser meehr und so
irgendwo anders ist eine riesen
Überschwemmung und da denkt man ja ja
das ist schon schlimm mit dem Klima und
so und dann kommen die Fußballergebnisse
und dann ist irgendwie alles wieder wie
vorher also anders als kriegerische
Auseinandersetzung z.B oder Pandemie ja
das sind alles Sachen die man so ganz
unmittelbar das ist ja wird ganz viel
getriggert im Kopf ne da kapieren wir oh
das ist jetzt ein richtig große Gefahren
das ist gefährlich das ist obwohl wir
das ja alles Wissen über die
Klimakatastrophe und obwohl wir eine
ungefähre Vorstellung davon haben was
wohl alles mit dieser Welt passiert im
21 Jahrhundert wenn wir das nicht in den
Griff kriegen das ist das immer noch
total vernachlässigte Thema unserer Zeit
ja weißt du was ich interessant finde
und deswegen man könnte ja sagen Dubai
ne ich meine ausgerechnet in Dubai
machst du das und es gibt ja auch so
eine interessante Recherche sind Papiere
geliegt worden wie man offenbar
sozusagen den diversen
Staaten speziell industriest Daten
anbieten will pass auf da können wir
noch ein bisschen mehr Gas und da können
wir noch ein bisschen mehr Öl und so
weiter also am Rande dieser eigentlichen
Klimakonferenz wird man weiterhin
versuchen richtig harte Lobbyarbeit für
Öl und Gas zu machen andererseits denke
ich manchmal Dubai ist ein sehr sehr
guter Ort um das zu machen das ist ein
sehr wohlhabendes Land das heute schon
eigentlich zeigt was das bedeutet was da
auf uns zukommt ganz konkret also dem
Meerwasser wird Salz entzogen ja
riesigen salzungsanlagen die da laufen
Gemüse und Salate wachsen nur noch auf
Nährlösungen in Gewächshäusern die
Hotels kühlen ihre schwimbecken ja
woanders gr im Sommer über lange Zeit
genau überall Klimaanlagen ja wie in
unseren Wintern W wenn wir heizen das
Leben findet komplett drinen ST g grö
Teil der Wüste und unbewohnbar ja ganze
komplexe von Wolkenkratzern ja zum
Wohnen und Arbeiten sind unterirdisch
miteinander verbunden da unten kann man
einkaufen da kann essen da kann man
Sport treiben da gibt es die Kitas da
gehst du ins Kino also falls gewünscht
kannst du sozusagen tagelang auf frische
Luft verzichten so so schreibt das
Christian gein jetzt in seinem in seinem
Kommentar und das finde ich so
interessant ja dass man dort eigentlich
genau sich angucken kann welche
Konsequenz das am Ende haben wird wenn
wir das nicht in den Griff kriegen ja
das das zeigt das und das zeigt das aber
zu wohlwollend ja weil da kann man auch
ausrechnen wenn wir jetzt alle
Wolkenkratzer die da stehen wenn wir die
alle komplett grünen ne also W das kann
man ja machen ne Ben gardening ne also
es ist wird ja überall gemacht in
Singapur gemacht mittlerweile gibt es
solche Simulationen für die Straßen von
Palmer de Mallorca ja wie können wir das
sozusagen optimal begrünen was heißt das
also ja das man kann sich alles
vorstellen man kann ja wenn die Autos
mal aus den Straßen raus hat und dann
kann man da noch weitere Grünzonen
machen oder man baut
mit mit raffiniertester Technik kannst
du 200 m hohe Bürokomplexe machen die
aussehen wie eine einzige regenwaldhalle
im Zoo mhm also das sind alles so Sachen
und damit könntest Du bis zu 2°
möglicherweise Städte runterkühlen mhm
ja wir jetzt das ist alles schön od das
ist eine gute Sache und das klingt alles
so wie ach wir kriegen den Klimawandel
doch in Griff ja wir kriegen den
vielleicht in Dubai ja abgefedert und
wir kriegen ih in Singapur abgefedert
und vielleicht sehen auch alle deutschen
Städte irgendwann mal so aus aber ich
meine es gibt riesige Regionen in der
Welt ja das ganze Afrika südlich der
Sahara
ich meine da wird sowas alles nicht
gebaut werden ist das Geld nicht dafür
da ja da klingt das auch völlig albern
also da verdursten die Leute nach wie
vor da wächs auf den Weiden da geht das
Vieh kaputt ja migrationsbewegung haben
wir letzte mal drüber gesprochen und so
weiter und so weiter also da bricht der
die die totale Hölle aus nur weil wir
vielleicht unsere Städte unsere Städte
hübsch kriegen ja und wenn weil wir
immer trickreicher werden wie wir
weiterhin fossile Energieträger
irgendwie ja dann doch noch nutzen
können damit bestimmte Industriezweige
nicht verlöschen ja wie wir neue Form
der Wassergewinnung bei uns haben und
wir unsere Städte so herrlich grün
machen aber das gilt doch nicht für die
ganze Welt ich meine da gibt's
Milliarden von Menschen die werden von
diesen Segnungen komplett ausgeschlossen
sein weil so schnell wird das alles gar
nicht immer und überall gehen also wir
denken da viel zu sehr an uns und dann
gucken wir uns das schöne Dubai an und
denken ja sehen unsere Städte halt
irgendwann Hamburg aus wie Dubai ja aber
das ist doch nicht die Lösung machen wir
uns nichts vor das ist
Schönheitschirurgie am krebskranken
Patienten so und und jetzt Richard sind
wir finde ich genau bei unserem Thema
heute also ich glaube worüber es keinen
Zweifel gibt ist
ähm wir gehen auf eine Zeit gigantischer
Veränderungen zu und was man auch immer
hört du hast jetzt auch das Wort
Katastrophe benutzt und so weiter man
hat das den Eindruck wir gehen da auf
einen Fiasko zu dass wir irgendwann
nicht mehr in den Griff kriegen und ich
habe quasi stellvertretend dafür habe
ich dieser Tage zwei sehr sehr
interessante
Interviews gelesen Historiker jeweils
der eine war Nil Ferguson über den wir
hier schon mehrfach gesprochen haben ein
ein Stück das überschrieben war mit
anderenfalls dürfte ein dritter
Weltkrieg immer näher rücken wenn du das
liest dann hast du das Gefühl stiwort
Gaza Stichwort Ukraine Stichwort Klima
und so weiter wir gehen kompletto in den
Untergang dann habe ich mich wenig
später mit Andrew moravsik beschäftigt
weiß nicht wie man den perfekt
ausspricht aber auch ein amerikanisch er
Politologe Princeton University der
genau das Gegenteil sagt der sagt nein
nein nein nein nein nein die Weltlage
ist nicht völlig inabil und der Westen
ist auch nicht völlig schwach im
Gegenteil
sagt im ukrainekrieg engagiert sich der
Westen genauso viel wie es se Interessen
entspricht
und auch ansonsten sieht das sozusagen
nicht den Untergang der Welt kommen im
Sinne von
wir leben in in kurz vorm Abgrund
sondern er sagt wir leben strukturell in
relativ guten Zeiten ja begründet das
auch und sagt nationalismus ist bei
weitem nicht so stark wie früher der
weltwe der Handel hat zugenommen auch
wenn es dann immer wieder
Unterbrechungen durch Konflikte und Kri
Kriege gibt und so weiter und sagt seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ist die Zahl der
Toten pro Kopf in allen Kriegen um 90%
gesunken und es gab jetzt wieder
Ausreißer durch durch syürien und die
Ukraine aber eigentlich beschreibt er
die Welt als einen Ort der relativ
sicher undab ist und ich glaube diese
beiden Pole dass die sind es die uns
immer so das Gefühl geben oh mann e und
wo gehen wir den jetzt hin woran glaubst
du glaubst du an den Untergang oder
glaubst du daran dass wir eine eine
Zukunft haben letzter Punkt noch in dem
Zusammenhang wir sind in der
Recherche auf einen Artikel von Hann
Richie gestoßen die Seite heißt our
world in data ja also unsere Welt in
daten.org und das sind mal wieder diese
cleveren jungen Leute ich glaube Oxford
in dem Zusammenhang die sich anschauen
wo sind wir eigentlich wenn es um das
Klima geht an welchem Punkt stehen wir
eigentlich und da liest du dann z.B ganz
nüchtern aufbereitet interessante Fakten
du liest z.B dass es lange Zeit immer
eine Korrelation gegeben hat zwischen
dem Reichtum von Staaten und dem CO2
Ausstoß aber seit einigen Jahrzehnten
schon entkoppelt sich das das heißt es
gibt Wachstum es gibt immer mehr
Wohlstand in den reichen Ländern
Deutschland ist z Beispiel dafür aber
auch Italien Frankreich Finnland und
viele viele mehr und gleichzeitig
entkoppelt sich sozusagen der CO2
Ausstoß das heißt es geht nach unten das
ist sehr interessant weil bisher immer
die These war je mehr Wachstum ja desto
mehr CO2 desto mehr Energie werden wir
brauchen aber die weisen nach und sagen
fossile Energie vor allen Dingen genau
und die sagen sogar das ist fand ich ein
sehr interessantes Argument weil das war
das erste was ich als Gegenargument im
Kopf hatte ich dachte na ja gut ich sag
mal die Batterie fürs Auto die wir in
Zukunft brauchen werden die lassen wir
ech einfach in China fertigen und damit
ja sehr sehr energieintensiv aber der
CO2 Ausstoß den die Produktion dieser
Batterie braucht den rechnen wir dann
einfach den Chinesen an aber gefahren
wird sie hier aber die die haben das
bereinigt die haben gesagt nein selbst
wenn man das mit einkalkuliert ist es so
dass unsere CO2 Kurve sozusagen
runtergeht werd unsere Wachstumskurve
nach oben geht das fand ich sehr
interessant und die zweite interessante
Botschaft wenn man mal 10 Jahre
zurückschaut
Photovoltaik ist um 90% das ist irre
viel günstiger geworden im Vergleich zu
vor 10 Jahren windkraft ist um 70%
günstiger geworden im Vergleich zu vor
10 Jahren das heißt da tut sich richtig
was und wir erzählen uns aber häufig
auch diese Erfolgsgeschichten die da
gibt und die wir gerade auch dabei sind
zu schreiben die erzählen wir uns
irgendwie nicht stattdessen höre ich
immer nur polyrise und noch mehr Krise
und Apokalypse und morgen geht die Welt
unter und das ist etwas ich gerne auch
mal dich fragen würde Richard als jemand
ja woran liegt dasier ich könnte dir
eine gute Antwort geben die nicht von
mir ist sondern ich habe am Sonntag
wird jetzt ausgeschreidene Sendung die
ich wieder mal mit Ivan krastev machen
durfte ja ja großartig jetzt am Sonntag
son jetzt am sonnag abends irgendwann
nach 11 Uhr oder so ja 11:30 also sich
mit krassev zu unterhalten ist immer ein
großes intellektuelles Vergnügen und ich
habe ihn genau das gleiche gefragt ich
habe ih gleich am Anfang gesagt also
Krieg in der Ukraine Krieg im Nahen
Osten das alles scheint ja jede
menschheitsfortschritt hohen zu sprechen
ja so dass also die allermeisten
Menschen in Europa mittlerweile nicht
nur in Deutschland sehr pessimistisch in
die Zukunft gucken und habe ich gefragt
ob er diese Sicht teilt und da hat er
als erstes den entwaffnenden Satz auf
seine unnachahmliche Art und Weise
gesagt ist ja kein Wunder dass wir
pessimistisch in die Zukunft blicken wir
sind ja auch maßlos überaltete
Gesellschaften das ist ein großes Thema
ne dem das ist mal das allererste ja und
er sagt also guck mal wie viele Länder
in der Welt gerade enorm optimistisch in
die Zukunft gucken ja das sind im
Regelfall die Länder wo es sehr sehr
viele junge Leute gibt weil es eben eine
Angewohnheit vieler junger Leute
normalerweise ist optimistisch in die
Zukunft zu gucken ja bei uns wird das
Klima ja das unsere jungen Leute so
pessimistisch macht ja von Leuten in
unserem Alter Markus erzeugt ja und wir
haben die mittlerweile in unseren Wand
gezogen mit unserem Pessimismus na ja
das war natürlich nicht seine einzige
Antwort aber sein sind zwei Antworten
das eine sind wir sind überaltet und der
zweite Teil der Antwort sind wir sind
Europäer wir sind diejenigen die jetzt
gerade nicht mehr wissen wie sie sich in
der neuen Welt orientieren sollen andere
Länder fahren jetzt ihre klevereren
Strategien um sich neu in der Welt
aufzustellen und es gibt ja auch viele
Staaten in der Welt die deutlich
größeres Wachstum haben jetzt
mittlerweile als Europa und da herrscht
natürlich ein anderer Optimismus vor und
das ist richtig ne wir wir dürfen müssen
immer daran denken dass unsere Sicht auf
die Welt a es geht alles im Bach runter
und B es geht wir langfristig sowieso
schief das ist unsere Sicht auf die Welt
es ist nicht die Sicht der Mehrheit der
Menschen auf diesem Planeten auf die
Welt denn da ist es immer noch so also
immer noch natürlich nicht seit 100
Jahren so aber jetzt seit einigen Jahren
so dadurch dass ja der Lebensstand hat
global bei aller Armut die es gibt und
allen Kriegen die es gibt eher gewachsen
als gesunken ist ne die berühmten pinker
Zahlen über die wir hier schon oft
geredet haben von Steven Pinker der
gesagt hat wie viele Menschen prozentual
hungern denn heute wie viele Menschen
prozentual sterben denn in Kriegen wann
war es denn besser und dieses pinker
Gefühl das ist glaube ich sehr
verbreitet in vielen Ländern des
globalen Südens und das ist eben dieses
Gefühl was wir ganz und gar nicht haben
na wir sehen diese Statistiken mit zum
gewissen Kopfschütteln aber wir lassen
ih nicht an unser herzran genau das ist
der Punkt ich ähm eben gerade gedacht
dass du sagtest na ja wir sind alt und
wir sind Europäer und dann dachte ich ja
und wir sind dann auch noch deutsche
also da kommt da kommt das eine zum
anderen was zweifeln und Pessimismus
sozusagen angeht aber es ist schon
verstörend wenn man das sieht ne also
wenn du ich habe mit Florence Kaup
letzte Woche darüber gesprochen die
dieses schöne Buch über die Zukunft eine
Bedienungsanleitung gemacht hat und die
sagt es ist interessanterweise so in in
Russland ist seit dem Einmarsch in der
Ukraine der Optimismus gewachsen und
zwar von 40 auf ungefähr 50 52% und der
Anteil umgekehrt der traurig depressiven
ist von von von ungefähr 40 auf knapp
30% gesunken wie kann das sein dass also
Krieg optimistischer macht und sie sagt
das hat halt damit zu tun dass man dann
plötzlich das Gefühl hat man hat was in
der Hand man gestaltet etwas es passiert
nicht mit uns sondern wir alten ist
aktiv und selbst bei einem so
grauenvollen Ding wie diesem mit diesem
Krieg gegen die Ukraine haben die Russen
der einfache Russe offensag sichtlich
plötzlich das Gefühl na ja aber wir wir
können da jetzt irgendwas gestalten
umgekehrt unsere Jugend weil du gerade
sagtest alte Gesellschaft
86% also sind ja fast alle der jungen
Deutschen sorgen sich um die Zukunft
interessanterweise nicht so sehr um ihre
eigene weil so erlebe ich die auch die
eigene Zukunft da schauen die durchaus
positiv drauf aber sie sorgen sich um
die Zukunft der Welt weißt du ich sag
noch mal woran das liegt früher war das
so dass man den Weisheiten seiner Eltern
misstraut hat ja also jede Generation
hat versucht sich gegen die frühere
Generation abzugrenzen ne und die die
die weiheiten mein Elternhaus war ja nur
ein bisschen special aber sag wir für
die meisten das waren noch so Weisheiten
die stammten aus einer Kindheit im
Dritten Reich und einer Jugend und
Arbeitswelt aus der Adenauerzeit so und
dass man dann in den 70er 80er Jahren
gesagt hat ja das sind nicht mehr die
Maxim und Reflexionen die mich hier
besonders beeindrucken ne es hat eine
neue Zeit eine neue Welt angefangen also
ich bin nicht so drauf wie meine Eltern
mhm heute sind die Eltern die besten
Freunde ihrer Kinder ja und das heißt
man teilt mehr und mehr eine gleiche und
gemeinsame Weltsicht und damit hat
unsere Generation Markus die herrliche
Chance ihren Pessimismus so an die
jüngere Generation weiterzugeben dass er
dort tatsächlich ankommt und dass sie
sich nicht dagegen abgrenzen ich glaube
dieses psychologische Problem wird
unterschätzt also wir brauch mehr
Rebellion der Kinder die unsere besten
Freunde sind ja gegen gewisse
pessimistische Weisheiten die wir so
gerne
verkünden ja wobei erlebst du also
jetzt also psychologisch unsere
Generation dann auch noch älter ja
erlebst du die wirklich als fast
ausnahmslos pessimistisch ich nicht
ich schon also nicht pessimistisch jetzt
genau dasselbe wie bei der Jugend ja
also ich bin ja umzingelt von Menschen
meines Alters die also se zu um die 60
sind und viele davon haben wirklich ein
gutes Leben und sind sehr glücklich und
zufrieden mit ihrem Leben aber wie oft
ich den Satz höre im Freundes und
Bekanntenkreis ja das geht alles sowieso
den Bach rter und bin ich froh dass ich
noch so ein gutes Leben gehabt
hab diese Haltung was wir unseren
Kindern für eine Welt überlassen ja ich
weiß da auch keinen Rad mehr ja da bin
ich doch froh dass ich schon 60 bin also
das sind Sätze die höre ich ganz ganz
oft ja deswegen ist es so gut sich mal
mit diesen Daten zu beschäftigen und mal
klar zum Maen auf der einen Seite dass
wir gar nicht so schlecht sind wie wir
uns manchmal machen also ich meine
solche Daten wie die die ich vorhin
vorgetragen habe die die die ermuntern
ein ja die sagen pass auf da geht mehr
als wir im Moment denken wir haben die
Technologie wir haben auch eine Idee
davon wo die Reise hingehen könnte also
das ist nicht nur schlecht finde ich ich
ich
habe in der Beschäftigung Florence Kaup
ja die sagt die Zukunft hat zwei
Geschwister die Gegenwart und die
Vergangenheit ja und sie sie verweist
auf das Jahr
1923 also genau 100 Jahre her genau und
gab ja wenn du dich erinnerst Anfang des
Jahres auch ein spiegeltitel sogar dazu
ein Horrorjahr haben die damals
beschrieben und zwar nicht 2023 sondern
1923 m mhm wo aus der Inflation von 1922
dann im Jahre 23 eine Hyperinflation
geworden ist immer so als Beispiel in
Berlin hat im November
1923 ein Kilogramm Roggenbrot
233 Milliarden Mark gekostet und ein
Kilogramm Rindfleisch 4,8 Billionen das
muss man sich mal vorstellen und dann
haben die Leute mit Schubkarren ja ihre
Lohnauszahlung gekriegt und zwar täglich
richtig ja macht keinen Sinn im Monat
weil am Ende des Monats ist das nur noch
Pfennig wert was irgendwo wo eine
Milliarde drauf steht und dann sind die
direkt also haben die Schubkarren in den
Laden man überleg mal aber auch was für
eine Verzweiflung ne wenn wenn du wenn
du in der Zeit lebst wenn du merkst okay
die Arbeit von morgens bis abends und
das waren durchaus anstrengende Zeiten
das bringt alles gar nichts das lohnt
sich gar nicht ich ich kann das Geld gar
nicht so schnell verdienen wie es auf
der anderen Seite entwertet wird ne
genau ja auch Thema Thema Krieg Thema
Militär hat man auch nicht mehr so parat
1923 beginnt das Jahr mit der Besetzung
des rohgebiets durch französische
Truppen und zwar deswegen weil die
deutsche Regierung mit ihren
Reparationszahlungen ne Stichwort erster
Weltkrieg gen mus goldmen goldmzahen Z
groß nicht mehr hatten genau und dann
gehen die die Franzosen hin und besetzen
einfach mal das
rohrgebiet schade dass die 1923 W ja
schön esen man hätte seine Schulden in
Papiergeld bezahlen können da man ja
gerade dabei war billionenscheine zu
drucken wäre man seine Schulden mit
einem einzigen Schein los geworden den
man dann nach Paris geschickt hätte nein
also tatsächlich waren die in der Zeit
der Hyperinflation ja nicht mehr in der
Lage ihre Kriegsschulden zu begleichen
ne die Reparationszahlung das ging
eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr und dann
war innenpolitisch total unstabil ja war
ja ohnehin darf man nicht vergessen also
der der Erste Weltkrieg war zu Ende
gegangen und die Ver reitete Erzählung
in Deutschland die durchstoßlegende war
ja dass die sogenannten
novemberverbrecher also die Politiker
die damals den Friedensvertrag
unterzeichnet haben dass die das
deutsche Volk verraten hätten ja und
ihben quasi den den dem dem tapferen
Soldaten den delch in den Rücken gerammt
hätte
GHE durchstoßlegende und es gab eine
erhebliche Zahl von Menschen die dachten
wir haben eigentlich den Ersten
Weltkrieg nicht verloren und sofort
eigentlich gerne wieder in den Krieg
gegen Frankreich gezogen wären die
Unruhe und die Unzufriedenheit in der
Gesellschaft die war natürlich großartig
für
heilserklärer jeglicher Form genau es
ist auch die Zeit der
inflationsheiligen ja die
inflationsheiligen im doppelten Sinne ja
einmal inflationsheilig weil es in die
Zeit der Inflation fällt und zweitens
weil sie inflationär auftraten und das
waren jene Menschen die mit neuen und
radikalen Welterklärungen ja daher kam
und sagten ihr müsst die meld mal aus
der Perspektive der Perspektive der
Perspektive das ist die einzig richtige
das war politisch ne also der der der
Faschismus auch in Deutschland ne man
denke an den jungen
Hitler oder an den kapputsch den es
gegeben hat ne es gab ja viele viele
reaktionäre Militärs in der damaligen
Zeit das gilt für den aufkommenden
Kommunismus ne der damals ja auch
überall in der Gesellschaft verfangen
hat die Leidenschaft für den
bolschwismus in in Russland Faszination
für
Lenin guck mal da radikaler Umbruch
alles ist m möglich alles kann neu
gemacht werden ja hat mit dem Faschismus
gemeinsam diese Vorstellung dass die
Demokratie so ein Augiasstall wäre der
richtig mal so richtig schön ausgemistet
werden muss ja und dann gab es auch noch
alle Taus andere Sachen esoterische
Weisheiten es gab unheimlich viele
religiöse Spinner in dieser Zeit die
sind uns nicht so e groß in Erinnerung
gewesen aber die gab sowohl in den
etablierten Kirchen wie außerhalb davon
so
welterlösungsformeln es gab
durchgeknallte Physiker die verrückte
Dinge behauptet haben über die Zukunft
der Welt und so also das ist irre wie
viele Menschen damals kam und dann noch
viele andere Sachen die dauerhaft Kultur
gut geworden sind die Anthroposophie von
odudolf Steiner die Psychoanalyse von
Sigmund Freud das sind ich das ist ja
kein Quatsch aber das sind Perspektiven
den Menschen oder die Welt mit gänzlich
anderen Augen zu sehen Gen das ist der
Punkt große Veränderung und das hatte
das hat das war un unheimlich in in
diesen Zeiten des Umbruchs als man das
Gefühl hatte keinen festen Boden mehr
unter den Füßen zu haben oder diese
wunderschöne Formulierung von dem
Philosophen Georg lukatch ne wir leben
in einer transzendentalen
Obdachlosigkeit ich das schon
gen transzendentale obdachlos genau sagt
also bei Kant Kant ne Kant guckt in den
bestirnten Himmel und fühlt sich in der
Welt geborgen und kann horcht in sich
hinein ja und erkennt das Sittengesetz
der Mensch mit seiner Pflicht ja und
diese beiden Dinge verankern den
Menschen in der Welt und L sagt ja der
Himmel gibt uns heute keinen Halt mehr
ja der ist keine Orientierungshilfe mehr
für unser Leben und was ist denn da dass
die innere Pflicht das Sittengesetz der
Mensch mit seiner Moralität alles unter
der Voraussetzung dass gerade der erste
Weltkrieg getobt hatte ja der die alles
barbarische im Menschen hervorgekehrt
hat und alle alten Ordnungen zerstört
hatte und das ist glaube ich eine eine
sehr gute Beschreibung für die 1920er
Jahre die transzendentale
Obdachlosigkeit und die spannende Frage
wäre so ein bisschen zuck wie sieht das
in 2023 ja also ich finde die Analogie
du hast ja jetzt viele schon genannt es
ist wirklich spannend ich meine auch die
die die die Name auch die Länder die da
fallen ne das du du denkst okay reden
wir jetzt von damals oder reden wir von
heute in Sachsen und in Thüringen haben
sich da im Oktober die sogenannten
proletarischen arbeiterregierungen
gebildet ne da haben die Kommunisten
über eine Revolution nach russischem
Vorbild nachgedacht und gleichzeitig
haben völkische Nationalisten die Zeit
reif gehalten für eine Diktatur das was
du gerade beschrieben hast der
augjasstall jetzt muss man hier auf den
Tisch gehauen werden jetzt mus unser
Land zurück richtig am 9 November ich mE
sehr interessant 9 November ne ein
großes wichtiges und eigentlich in mit
Blick auf die jüngere Vergangenheit ein
glückliches Datum aber am 9 November 23
putscht Hitler und startet von München
aus seinen sogenannten Marsch auf Berlin
nach Vorbild von von Mussolini und
gleichzeit
haben wir auch schon oft drüber
gesprochen ne die die Gleichzeitigkeit
der der Ereignisse gleichzeitig
schreitet die Elektrifizierung voran und
ermöglicht plötzlich industrielle
Massenproduktion Siemens und AEG werden
plötzlich wieder
weltmarktunternehmen das heißt die Zeit
vor 100 Jahren ist im Grunde ähnlich wie
die Gegenwart von starken Veränderung
nur D den Leuten in in Europa natürlich
viel viel viel schlechter ging wir haben
heute noch den Spruch man muss die
Arbeitslosen von der Straße holen das
ist ein Spruch der aus den 20er Jahren
weil damals stieg natürlich also am Ende
ne kam ja noch die die
Weltwirtschaftskrise dazu also Grund
hast du die verheerte Zeit nach dem
Ersten Weltkrieg die ganzen
kriegsinvaliden die ganzen
verschwörungserzählung die ganzen
inflationsheiligen die Elektrifizierung
wälzt das Leben um ne muss ich mal
gucken wie sah 1918 der Alexanderplatz
aus oder oder die Bahnhof zo und
Umgebung und wie das ganze 10 Jahre
später aus die Mode veränderte sich auf
einmal der der Blick auf die Frau
veränderte sich also das waren
unglaublich viele Veränderung der
Autoverkehr ne der der innerhalb von 10
Jahren von fast von null auf 100 geht
diese enormen Umbrüche menschliche
Psyche ist nie gut da drin so schnelle
Veränderungen ja die auf der anderen
Seite wir haben schon mal drüber
gesprochen dann noch immer trotzige
Gegenreaktionen hervorrufen Ivan krastev
mit dem du gerade gesprochen hast ist
interessant der sagt äh wir müssen uns
erstmal darüber klar werden dass all
diese Dinge jetzt passieren und wenn wir
sagen Elektrifizierung heute ist das
große Stichwort KI das das von der viele
Leute sagen pass auf das wird eine
solche disruption
nach sich ziehen die Welt danach wird
eine andere sein und so war sie es auch
nach der Elektrifizierung also solche
riesigen Transformationen finden statt
also manchmal habe ich den Eindruck
Leute sagen ja komm geh mir weg mit
deiner KI es sind so ein paar Nerds ir
im Keller und die machen da ihr Zeug
aber am Ende ist ja vieles dann doch
nicht so gekommen wie wir es dachten
doch es gibt solche Transformationen
Ivan krastev hat das neulich in einem
Interview auch gesagt er meinte es ist
völlig egal ob die SPD regiert oder ob
die CDU regiert ob eine progressive
Regierung regiert oder eine konservative
Regierung an der Macht ist worum beide
nicht herumkommen werden ist die Welt
von gestern gibt es nicht mehr und wir
müssen Dinge neu denken und sogar und
das fand ich den spannenden Gedanken
dabei wir müssen auch sozusagen
anerkennen dass wir nicht für alles die
perfekte Lösung haben sondern wir irren
jetzt quasi voran ja dieser dieser
dieser Begriff den wir schon oft benutzt
haben wir müssen es ausprobieren wir
müssen gucken aber wir müssen ganz
sicher die Leute darauf vorbereiten wir
müssen den Leuten das klar sagen
deswegen wäre es auch so hilfreich wenn
man den Leuten nicht weiter sagt was auf
1,5° das werden wir schon machen
während in Dubai jetzt Leute zusammitzen
die sagen pass auf über 1,5° reden wir
eigentlich gar nicht mehr lasst uns
überlegen was es bedeutet 2 Grad klim
wir das wirkte so als H Scholz eine Rede
aus aus der Schublade gezogen die er vor
10 Jahren gehalten hat also einfach
nicht einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß und
wichtig und spannend finde ich auch wir
haben ja schon häufiger drüber geredet
das Dilemma des Konservativismus na wir
leben in einer Zeit rasantester
Veränderung und
konservativ bedeutet ja dem wortsin und
das ist ja auch seine Berechtigung ja
zu versuchen das was früher mal gut war
zu bewahren aber eben nicht unter den
gleichen Bedingungen sondern unter
veränderten Bedingungen und das ist eben
die ganz ganz große Schwierigkeit wenn
die Zeit sehr sehr sehr schnell geht
dann geht die Anpassungsleistung der
Menschen nicht schnell genug im Kopf mit
und was wir ja eigentlich behalten
wollen wenn wir irgendetwas
konservatives in uns spüren dann ist das
man möchte irgendwo seine seelenheimat
retten genau ne aber diese seelenheimat
kann man nur dann retten wenn man sie
auch Stück für Stück und den ganz ganz
vielen kleinen Schritten an sich
verändernde Gegebenheiten anpasst und
das geht nur wenn es nicht so schnell
geht und sonst wird Konservativismus
alberner trotz also der der Versuch mit
der Luftpumpe die Windrichtung zu ändern
das ist das was aus ja das ist das was
aus konservativ wird ja wenn wenn man
nicht mitkommt ne also wenn wenn man es
quasi nicht schafft das Gute und das
bewahrenswerte von früher unter
veränderten Vorzeichen zu halten dann
bleibt nur noch
Fundamentalopposition richtig einfach
Fundamentalopposition einfach einfach
der gegensein ist sozusagen trotz und
das war in den 1920er Jahren ganz ganz
genauso mhm interessant ist ja
vielleicht muss man das auch noch mal
kurz nachttragen wenn man sich mal mit
dieser Zeit das jaah konkret 1923
beschäftigt dieses narrativ Deutschland
wurde damals in diese Inflation und dann
in die Hyperinflation reingetrieben und
die diese dieses gigantische
verarmungsprogramm weil sozusagen die
anderen so sehr auf ihren
Reparationszahlungen bestanden ein
kleines aber nicht unwichtiges Detail in
dem Zusammenhang auf dass man stößt wenn
man mal tiefer eintaucht
ist das ist nur bestenfalls ein Teil der
Wahrheit der andere Teil der Wahrheit
ist und ich glaube das ist fast der
wesentlichere schon der Krieg den die
Deutschen ja auch wollten war vor allen
den durch Anleihen finanziert der Staat
hat sich das Kaiserreich die haben sich
irrsinnig verschuldet und haben
sozusagen durch Anleihen diesen Krieg
finanziert die ih dann jetzt in dieser
Phase um die Ohren fliegen das ist auch
Teil der Wahrheit deswegen muss man
immer aufpassen ne so nach dem Motto da
gab's diese bösen auf der anderen Seite
und wir waren dann quasi Opfer so
einfach ist die Sache an nicht also dass
die Deutschen da im ersten welkrieg
Opfer gewesen natürlich Teiler
Schwachsinn die ganze Diskussion der
letzten 20 Jahre ging immer darum waren
die Deutschen die Hauptschuldigen ja
oder waren sie Mitschuldige unter
anderen das ist eigentlich die Frage die
beim ersten weg weil die Deutschland
musste ja die allein Kriegsschuld auf
sich nehmen nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg
men sie unterzeichnen dass sie die die
einzig Schuldigen waren die anderen
haben sich dann die Sieger haben sich
weiß gewaschen aber niemand bestreitet
dass Deutschland einen maßgeblichen
Anteil am Ersten Weltkrieg hat ja und
dass Deutschland auch mutmaßlich das
Land gewesen ist das diesen Krieg am
meisten gewollt hat die Frage ist nur
wie sah das in England und in Frankreich
aus und so weiter und da gab es
natürlich vergleichbare Kräfte genau
aber wollen nur mal auf aufusagen den
Zusammenhang mit der Hyperinflation
hinweisen das ist sehr interessant sich
das noch mal so klar zu machen der der
andere Punkt ist ich hatte
letzte Woche glaube ich war es einen
irgendwie verstörenden Moment in der
Sendung da sitzt Jürgen trtin den ich
vor allen Dingen publizistisch sehr
schätze der schreibt immer wieder echt
gute Sachen und auf seiner Homepage z.B
kannst Du aktuell gerade mal eine sehr
nüchterne aber wirklich gute Erklärung
des nauskonfliktes finden empfehle ich
wirklich sehr aber dieser und gerade
weil ich ihn Schätze und weil er ein
kluger Mann ist sitzt da jürgendr htin
und sagt
der der der der Friedrich März der hat
sowas
trampeskes und da habe ich mich
erschrocken weil ich dachte
nee jetzt Friedrich märz mit mit Trump
zu vergleichen das das geht mir sehr
viel zu weit
äh und das das das zeigt sozusagen wie
sehr wir bereit sind dann so
holzschnittartig plötzlich zuzuspitzen
politischche Vergleiche
ja solche Vergleiche sind sowieso fast
und immer überall gehen die schief ja
Friedrich märz mit Trump zu vergleichen
ich finde es geht einfach gar nicht was
richtig ist ist das was du sagst es ist
natürlich auch Friedrich märz wird das
morgen gestalten müssen ja nur die AFD
verspricht die Vergangenheit zu
gestalten aber das das wird nicht
reichen SN wir müssen das morgen gest
die CDU versucht Wahlkämpfe zu gewinnen
mit einem Konservativismus den sie wenn
sie in der Regierung ist nicht einlösen
kann mhm da bin ich fest von überzeugt
sie sie spricht das Gefühle von Menschen
an die sie in ihrem Herzen tragen und
die auch völlig berechtigte Gefühle sind
wo aber überhaupt nicht klar ist dass
wenn man in der Regierungsverantwortung
ist wie man dann tatsächlich eine
Politik machen möchte die diesen
Gefühlen adäquat Rechnung trägt weil
einfach zu vieles im Augenblick bei
diesen rasanten Veränderungen
hinwegespüt wird und sich nicht wird
behaupten lassen ohne dass es trotzig
ist ist und trotzig zu sein kann man in
der Opposition immer deutlich besser als
in der Regierung das stimmt ich sehe das
tatsächlich anders ich glaube dass da
ein paar sehr gute Leute sind
die die in der Lage sein werden das
irgendwann konstruktiv zu gestalten ich
glaube die Frage ist noch nicht
beantwortet so so W ich will nicht sagen
dass sie definitiv nicht beantwortet ist
aber es ist irrsinnig
schwierig also du kannst dein
konservatives Herz in der Opposition
deutlich besser kultivieren als wenn du
tatsächlich in der
Regierungsverantwortung bist du musst
mal überlegen mit was für Ideen ist die
Ampel gestartet und was hat die letzten
zwei Jahre beschäftigt ja also die die
Ampel ist mit Vorstellung dass also sich
der Grünen ne das Klima das ganz ganz
große Thema das war das Thema ihres
Wahlkampfs ja und dann kommt der Krieg
in der Ukraine in ostkonflikt und so
weiter und eigentlich ist man ständig
mit anderen Dingen viel mehr beschäftigt
als das was man eigentlich wollte und
wenn du jetzt so ein Heeres Programm
hast wie dem Konservativismus wieder
eine Stimme zu geben oder eben zu gucken
wie man den adäquat umsetzen kann in
Politik dann ist das beim politischen
Tagesgeschäft mit all den Aufregungen
und Erregungen und all den Kontingenten
Dingen also den Dingen die man nicht
vorher planen kann ein unheimlich
schwieriges unterf also ich finde ich
finde Konservativismus geht viel eher
kommunalpolitisch wenn du mich fragst
also da kann man e eher noch so
Entscheidungen fällen wie viel Autos
wollen wir haben und wie viel Fahrräder
wollen wir haben
ich ich denke je kleiner das ganze ist
je regionaler das ist ja umso mehr
lassen sich Sitten und Gebräuche z.B
fliegen aber nicht auf Bundesebene ist
interessanter Punkt ich ich muss da
denken an belid i den Oberbürgermeister
von Hannover den Grünen der ja
interessanterweise auch gewählt worden
ist maßgeblich weil er versprochen hat
ich mache euch die Innenstadt autofrei
und jetzt geht die SPD genau aus dieser
Koalition raus und sagt du pass mal auf
äh das wollen wir jetzt alles nicht mehr
das wird nicht passieren und ich
erinnere mich wie er der wie er bei mir
in der Sendung saß und das erklärt hat
und ich ich war irgendwie fasziniert
davon und dachte wow chapau an Hannover
wenn wenn die Bevölkerung sowas so
mitgeht und offensichtlich hat sich da
ein Klima verändert und das das ist das
was mir dann Angst macht oder auch wenn
man eben jemanden wie märz mit Trump
vergleicht was ich für völlig unzulässig
halte aus vielen vielen Gründen dann
denke ich und da kommst du jetzt ins
Spiel in deinem vierten Band der
Philosophiegeschichte mache die Welt da
beschreibst du ja wie sich auch wirklich
schlaue Leute in diesen 20er Jahren z.B
innerhalb kürzester Zeit radikalisieren
und plötzlich ist jemand wie ein
Heidegger einfach jemand sag muss u der
er nähert sich plötzlich dem Faschismus
so an dass man sagt äh was ist denn da
eigentlich schief gelaufen ja genau also
aus einem aus einem konservativen wie
Martin Heidegger der im Schoß der Kirche
aufgewachsen ist ne der der eigentlich
Theologe werden wollte und
der als die die Nazis Auftrieb kriegen
ja gesagt hat das sind doch diejenigen
die für das gleiche streiten wie ich ne
also für konservative Werte für das alte
Deutschland gegen die moderne gegen den
Sittenverfall gegen den Kulturverlust
und so weiter und innerhalb ganz ganz
kurzer Zeit einer Art blitzbekehrung ja
zum Nazi wird und auch noch geglaubt hat
in seiner Hybris ne wie viele
Philosophen ja haben er könnte die Nazis
für seine Zwecke gebrauchen
ja der hatte ja eine ganz eigene
Vorstellung hat seinen eigenen
Nationalsozialismus erfunden den er aufs
engste mit dem Griechentum dem antiken
Griechentum verquickt hat also das wenn
wenn die Nazis irgendwas fremd war dann
war das das antike Griechentum die
wussten gar nicht wovon der Mann
überhaupt redet ja und wenn er das Wort
Metaphysik benutzte also alles das was
wir was wir nicht vermessen können was
wir nicht rational erklären können aber
trotzdem zur Welt dazu gehört und das
irgendwie griechisch fand ja das war das
was was was er griechisch nannte nannten
die Nazis völkisch die hatten also eine
ganz andere Vorstellung davon trotzdem
waren die sehr froh dass der für Sie
nützliche Idiot dann Rektor wurde ja und
sich dann wie die Axt im Walde benommen
hat also der hat dann so so so
wersportübung mit seinen Studenten
gemacht und was viel schlimmer war er
hat äh äh ganz viele sehr sehr
bedeutende Kollegen jüdische Philosophen
deren Karrieren zerstört abgesägt und so
weiter ja und das alles bei jemand der
wo man sagt der Prozess wie aus der
konservativen Heidegger ein Nazi wurde
der hat sich in Wochen
abgespielt ja also das ist doch verrückt
wo man denkt er Wste doch eigentlich ein
sehr intelligenter Mensch müsste doch
immun dagegen sein ja und dass da so
jemand mit kalter Lust ja sich extrem
radikalisiert mit all den brutalen
Konsequenzen die das hat das ist
erschreckend und das gleiche hat es auch
auf der anderen Seite gegeben also es
gab Philosophen die wie Georg lukatch
ist ein schönes Beispiel ja also in
Ungarn Sohn eines Bankdirektors gilt als
das größte philosophische Talent seiner
Zeit ja also wir reden vernehmen die
transzendentale Obdachlosigkeit stammt
wo ich gerade drüber gesprochen hat und
der will etwas ganz brav bürgerliches
machen will ein riesiges System der
Ästhetik schreiben kannst kannz Ästhetik
überarbeiten und so so richtig so ein
bildungsbürgerliches klassisches
universitätsthema ja wir reden jetzt so
von der Zeit um 1920 rum 1918 bis 1920
und der wird innerhalb von Mitglied
entscheidet sich Mitglied der
Kommunistischen Partei zu werden und
wird von da an politischer
Agitator der dann auch nach Ungarn geht
und und dann später in in in Ungarn auch
diverse Funktionen hatte und quer durch
Europa gesucht war vorher und es also
wir Lenin quasi als revolutionär
unterwegs was ja alles andere als eine
dauerhaft intellektuell anspruchsvolle
Aufgabe ist ne das fängt mal
intellektuell anspruchsvoll an und am
Ende geht's noch um eiskalte
Machtpolitik W ist dann im Alter wieder
ein sehr guter philosoph auf gewonen
aber wie wird so jemand der also so hoch
reflektiert ist und der an kannt ja also
an an Liberalen Werten geschult ist
innerhalb so kurzer Zeit Kommunist und
bleibt es auch nach der Machtübernahme
Stalins also ist das für mich so
verrückte dass jemand aus der Ferne von
Lenin fasziniert sein konnte der mit dem
zahrenreich da abgerechnet hat und etwas
Neues versucht also so 2 D Jahre aus der
Distanz davon möglicherweise fasziniert
gewesen zu sein das find ich finde ich
nicht völlig abwegig man wusste ja auch
gar nicht wie das jetzt ganz genau
verort man hat das Gefühl hier fängt was
völlig neues an hier beginnt eine
moderne der Agrarstaat Russland ja der
der brutale Agrarstaat Russland der
macht jetzt den großen Sprung ja da wird
jetzt eine eine ganz moderne
Gesellschaft raus aber spätestens mit
Stalin mit den Schauprozessen ja mit mit
hom in der Ukraine ja genau der Hunger
der Hungerwinter Hunger Winter also man
merkt ein unglaublich brutal es Schwein
kann man ja gar nicht anders sagen und
dass man dann dem noch soangee die
Stange hält wie auch z.B Ernst Bloch
ebenfalls bedeutender Philosoph ne der
20er 30er Jahre das Prinzip Hoffnung ne
aktueller Titel übrigens da schließt
sich der Kreis zur Klimakonferenz genau
ja und dass dass solche Leute so lange
mit Gewalt an etwas glauben wollten dass
wenn sie es auch nur lang genug aus der
Nähe gesehen hätten sie einfach nur
hätte bestürzen und Abschrecken müssen
und das finde ich persönlich wahnsinnig
interessant eine große Bildung und eine
hohe Intellektualität und ein wacher und
scharfer Geist schützen dich nicht davor
verbrecherischen Ideologien auf den Leim
zu kriechen ja oder dich in irgendeinen
mythischen Unsinn zu verrennen das
stimmt ist ist es nicht sogar so und das
ist dann sozusagen der wirklich
gefährliche Teil dass gerade diese Leute
und das erlebst du ja auch zum Teil
jetzt wenn Du Dir mal so dieses die die
die die die teils wirklich krude
Argumentation der der globalen linken
wenn man so s wie den Bezug auch auf
Gaza dir anschaust oder die Hamas ins
besondere dass man natürlich das ist
oder dass es besonders gefährlich ist
weil diese Leute natürlich Kraft ihrer
intellektuellen Brillanz immer in der
Lage sind jeden noch so offensichtlichen
Unsinn argumentativ so zu verbrähmen und
zu verpacken dass man sagt ne aber du
hast trotzdem recht und es ist trotzdem
richtig und es ist trotzdem in Ordnung
das ist finde ich eigentlich das
wirklich gefährliche wenn es um
Weltanschauungen geht das ist überhaupt
keine Frage der Intelligenz
Weltanschauungen haben ein ganz andere
ganz andere Ursache als den den klaren
oder logischen Verstand starke
weltanschauliche Überzeugungen sind ein
rein emotionales Konstrukt das heißt
also da da entscheidet nachher das Herz
ja und dann kannst du deinen Verstand ja
als Marketingabteilung einsetzen ja um
im Nachhinein zu rechtfertigen was dein
Herz dir vorher erzählt hat das und das
deswegen ist es möglich dass
hochintelligente Menschen für totalitäre
Überzeugungen empfänglich waren es gibt
kaum ein Unrechtsstaat der nicht
irgendwo in seinen Chefetagen oder an
seinen Universitäten ja
hochintellektuelle geevolgsleute um sich
geschart hat die tatsächlich von allem
möglichen Unsinn schon überzeugt waren
mhm und das ist natürlich wenn man in
die Weltgeschichte guckt auch sehr
ernüchternd weil man würde sich ja sagen
also die große Historikerin Barbara
touchman ja die dieses berühmte Buch
geschrieben hat über die Torheit der
regierenden äh damals von Troja bis zum
Vietnamkrieg reichend und sich die Frage
gestellt hat warum ist der
menschheitsfortschritt in der Politik so
geringer als der menschheitsfortschritt
auf allen anderen Ebenen also was haben
wir für Fortschritte in der Medizin
gemacht für Fortschritte in der Technik
gemacht ja was haben wir für
Fortschritte gemacht in der
musikalischen Entwicklung und
künstlerischen Entwicklung und so weiter
wie kann das eigentlich sein dass wir
immer noch in die gleichen fallen laufen
wo man schon zur Zeiten des Trojanischen
Krieges reingestürzt ist warum gibt es
immer noch Kriege warum gibt es immer
noch Ideologien warum gibt es immer noch
politische
Kurzsichtigkeit warum sind die Leute
nicht in der Lage kurzfristige Vorteile
abzuwägen mit langfristigen Interessen
ja warum purzeln wir so oft in das
politisch nah liegende und übersehen die
die Folgen nicht und am Ende kommt es ja
kommt es da darauf hinaus
dass gerade in der Politik die
emotionalen Dinge so eine irrsinnige
Rolle spielen das heißt je stärker du
von etwas überzeugt bist und von etwas
total stark über überzeugt zu sein setzt
meistens Dummheit voraus ja je stärker
du davon überzeugt und so glaubhafter
kannst du es vertreten jemand der abwägt
und sagt na ja auf der einen Seite das
aber du musst ja auch berücken auf der
anderen Seite der ist meistens nicht
handlungsstark und der wird auch nicht
als charismatischer Führer wahrgenommen
richtig ja das heißt also ein gewisses
Maß an
Intellektualität verhindert dass das was
du sagst populär genug wird und dass du
es durchsetzen kannst und am Ende ist
Politik dann eben doch sehr sehr
weitgehend eine eine Angelegenheit des
Affekt und eben nicht der rationalen
Überlegung noch kurz zum Schluss Richard
Optimismus ne ähm und deswegen verehre
ich die andere Denkerin über die wir
schon gesprochen haben Florence gaup so
sehr die die hat dieses Buch gemacht und
sagt einen sehr interessanten Satz
Pessimismus ja oder Depression
Depression sagt sie ist eigentlich in
Wahrheit nicht die große Traurigkeit
dass die sie manchmal beschrieben wird
sondern Depression ist eigentlich unsere
Unfähigkeit uns unsere eigene Zukunft
vorzustellen und das geht so ein
bisschen Hand in Hand mit Ernst Bloch
den du gerade schon zitiert hast das was
wir heute im alltagsprachgebrauch so
häufig benutzen ne das Prinzip Hoffnung
da hilft nur noch Prinzip Hoffnung und
so weiter geht ja zurück auf dieses
berühmte Buch das Prinzip Hoffnung dass
ein Werk in drei Bänden ja Alter ja
genau mit dem er 38 beginnt ja also da
ist Hitler quasi auf dem Höhepunkt
seiner Macht wenn man so will gerade
Österreich und die Tschechoslowakei
annektiert und so weiter bereitet sich
auf den genau bereitet sich auf den
großen Krieg vor und schreibt es fertig
also diese Bände 1947 da ist Hitler tot
und das Dritte Reich liegt in Schutt und
Asche Prinzip Hoffnung was was was
können wir daraus heute noch ziehen also
das Unterfangen von Bloch ist quer durch
alleit und alle Kulturen ja Muster der
Hoffnung zu finden also zu gucken ist
alle Kulturen haben immer zu irgendeiner
Zeit an irgendetwas geglaubt und haben
dafür Bilder gefunden ja bei den
Ägyptern was völlig anderes als in der
Gotik z.B ja er guckt sich die Baustiele
an und sagt jemand der Pyramiden baut
der tickt natürlich anders als jemand
der der gotische Kathedralen baut der
der Spitzbögen baut der todeskristall so
nennt er die die Utopie der der alten
Ägypter das ist so diese diese
Vorstellung Transparenz auf Erden
herzustellen kubische Formen
geometrische Form so quasi als Leitbild
ja als als positives Bild der
Gesellschaft wogegen das gotische für
ihn ist der Wald ne also die gotischen
kathralen entstehen in in waldreichen
Gegenden und im Grunde genommen ist
dieses schöne wenn man heilig und
feierlich durch einen Wald oder eine
Allee geht das quasi abzubilden in der
in der Kirche und das ist das Streben
nach oben ja der der der Gott des
Christentums wohnt ja im Himmel der
wohnt ja über uns ne und bei den
Ägyptern gibt's ja kein über uns das
Jenseits ist nicht im Himmel bei den
Ägyptern ja das ist irgendwo wo man mit
der mit mit mit der Barke des Mondes
oder so irgendwie hingelangt aber es ist
nicht räumlich richtig verankert sondern
es ist so ein so ein ineinanderspiegeln
von Dieseits und Jenseits ja so wie die
die die die Pyramiden sind quasi ein
dieseitiger Ort der aber jenseitig
gefüllt ist wenn man das so sagen kann
und eben auch dieses dieses geomet
dieses transparente dieses von einer
Welt in die andere wandeln das ist ein
ganz anderes Bild als zu sagen wir haben
hier den Sockel auf der Erde ja und wir
haben da drüber das Himmelsgewölbe das
ist so eher eine Vorstellung des
Christentums und wo ich immer sag das
hat sicher eine Menge damit zu tun dass
gemeinsame Quelle Judentum Christentum
eben Wüstenbewohner waren und und für
für für die die Wüstenbewohner war die
Erde unwirtlich weil also fast alles
Wüste trockensaanne dor und so weiter
war und schön bei der bestirte Himmel
und da wollte man quasi sehen nicht hin
und die ägyptische Kultur ist ja vom
zyklich zyklischen überschwemmen des
Nils geprägt natürlich drumhum auch
Wüste aber da ist die ägyptische Kultur
nicht
ehsinnig fruchtbare Land gib das
fruchtbare Land was also immer
wiederkommt und deswegen ist die
Vorstellung der Ägypter zyklisch ja
immer wieder neu beginnt das Leben auf
der Erde auf der Erde ja und das
eigentliche Leben das in den Judentum
Christen auch im Islam ist ist eben das
jenseitiige Leben im Himmel und diese
diese Unterschiede rausgearbeitet zu
haben ne da mit sowas hat ers Bloch sich
beschäftigt und eben gesagt es gibt
immer wieder neue Formen und Muster der
Hoffnung und sich mit den alten Sachen
zu beschäftigen schlägt quasi den
mystischen Funken wieder ja also
sozusagen aus der Archäologie
vergangener Träume ja lässt sich neue
Kraft gewinnen auch an an eine gute
Zukunft zu denken stand heute äh
weil man beantwortet diese Frage ja im
Laufe seines Lebens auch immer wieder
neu und auch immer wieder anders aber
stand heute Ende 2023 ja bist du eher
Pessimist oder eher
[Musik]
Optimist ich würde sagen ist eine Frage
der Gemütslage ich kenne beide Zustände
Montag anders als Freitag Montag anders
als Freitag und ich finde diesen Zustand
gar nicht so verkehrt ja also ich meine
zu viel Optimismus macht blind aber zu
viel Pessimismus macht wahrscheinlich
auch blind und ich denke ich habe eine
ein buntes Mischungsverhältnis von
beiden normalerweise ist es ja so dass
der Verstand eigentlich pessimistischer
ist als das Herz richtig ja also bei mir
jedenfalls ist das eigentlich so mein
Herz will sich mit Pessimismus nicht
abfinden und deswegen erneuert es quasi
immer wieder so im Sinne von Ernst Bloch
ja also immer noch immer immer wieder
die Hoffnung also jeden Tag erneuert
mein Herz die Hoffnung und mein Verstand
versucht es ja auszu reden und es ist
immer eine Frage wie der Tag verläuft
wer von beiden
gewint schön herrlich Richard vielen
dank dir für heute ab viel gelernt von
dir und Weise gerne noch mal drauf hin
Sonntagabend im ztf du im Gespräch mit
Ivan krastev festnotiert bin ich
wahnsinnig gespannt darauf freue ich
mich wirklich sehr bis nächste Woche
Richard ja mach gut tchüs Markus tschüss
danke
dir eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
f